Das ist die wohl größte
Modelleisenbahnanlage der Welt.
Mehr als 500 Züge der Spur G rollen in den
„Modellbauwelten Bispingen“ über die Gleise.
Das Schienennetz ist
insgesamt 20 Kilometer lang.
Die Anlage selbst steht unter einer
auf Stelzen gebauten Skihalle
im norddeutschen Bispingen.
Also letztendlich ist es ja so,
dass wir im Grunde genommen
auf 12.000 Quadratmetern
7.000 Quadratmeter Modellbaufläche haben.
Das ist mit Abstand das Größte,
was es weltweit gibt − in dem Maßstab
und auch von der Schienenlänge her.
Und wir haben auch hier von den Themen
her fast weltweit alles zusammen.
Insgesamt sind es 50 Themenwelten.
Wir sind ... einmal links sind
wir in Sölden, Österreich.
Vorne weiter weg über die
Alpen ist dann Bayern.
Auf der rechten Seite haben wir dann im
Grunde genommen Ägypten,
’n bisschen Tansania, Afrika,
und da hinten geht’s nach Italien
und den [zum] Grand Canyon.
Rückblick: Im Februar dieses Jahres läuft der
Aufbau der XXL-Anlage noch auf Hochtouren.
Ein Team aus Tischlern und
Dekorateuren baut Landschaften aus Holz,
Kunststoff und Mörtel.
Mit dabei: Yogi Meiners,
der kreative Leiter des Projekts.
Auch in den Werkstätten wird gesägt,
geschraubt, geklebt und bemalt.
Ja, hier sind wir jetzt in einer
von unseren drei Werkstätten,
und hier bauen wir Häuser für alle
verschiedenen Themenbereiche:
Südamerika, Afrika, alles Mögliche.
Und hier werden halt dann die Häuser,
Brücken, kleine Figuren, alles Mögliche
gemacht und dann halt draußen eingebaut.
Bis die Anlage fertig ist,
dauert es insgesamt 16 Monate.
Hinter den Kulissen kümmert
sich Volker Hansen
um die 500 Züge und deren Wartung.
Bei einem Maßstab von 1:22,5 können die
Lokomotiven über einen Meter lang sein.
Sein Favorit: ein Modell von 1941.
Das ist eine der größten amerikanischen
Dampflokomotiven, die sogenannte „Big Boy“,
die hierzu restauriert worden ist.
Und wir haben noch ein
Modell davon ergattern können,
das zurzeit auch nicht mehr hergestellt wird.
Es ist aus Vollmetall und wiegt 53 Kilogramm.
Und da hab ich schon Schwierigkeiten, so ein
Modell wirklich auf die Gleise zu setzen.
Das macht man am besten zu zweit.
Um bei einer Anlage dieser Größe
nicht den Überblick zu verlieren,
sind alle Zugfahrten programmiert
und zentral koordiniert.
Das ist der sogenannte Leitstand,
über den die komplette Modelleisenbahn
gesteuert wird.
Diese Anlage ist ja digital gesteuert
und wird über Computer,
über Rechner, gefahren,
das heißt also über eine Software.
Wir haben hier 14 Computer eingebaut, wo
jedes Anlagenteil entsprechend
also gesteuert wird, alle Fahrzeuge
aufgerufen werden können.
Und das ganze Controlling
findet eigentlich von hier statt.
Besucher und Modelleisenbahn-Fans erwartet
hier eine Weltreise auf Schienen –
von Südtirol mit schroffen Bergen ist es nur
ein Katzensprung bis zur Freiheitsstatue.
Das kommt an.
Dass man einfach hier
viel Spaß haben kann, und ja,
für die Kinder das halt eben supertoll ist.
Das ist wirklich spannend gemacht. Man kann
oft hier durchgehen und findet noch was.
War spannend mal zu schauen, was jetzt da
neu ist und ... doch, macht ’n guten Eindruck.
Mit dieser Modelleisenbahnanlage
im XXL-Format hoffen die Betreiber nun
auf einen Eintrag
in das Guinness-Buch der Rekorde.